welcome back to what is now the second
to last in the lockdown math series so
we've been talking a lot about
exponential functions and complex
numbers and the interplay of the two of
them and I thought it might be a very
nice culminating topic to help bring it
all together and show really the full
breadth of what exponential functions
are and what they can be would be to
talk about raising I to the power I now
this is a this is a funny little
expression because usually if we think
about powers if we were doing something
like I to the fourth you know we know
how to think about it in terms of
repeated multiplication we're just
multiplying something by itself four
different times and in general you'd
like to think of I to the X as some
variant of that but as soon as X becomes
a complex number we should realize that
it's really nothing like the above so
it's really nothing like this instead
the way that we think about it is going
to have to be very related to the way
that we think about raising e to various
different numbers ie being that kind of
home base for us and in fact if we go
that's not sure where things are going
too much here if we go ahead and rewrite
that base I in terms of e it can help us
make sense out of this expression but I
don't want to do that I want you to do
that for me so if you head on over to 3b
1 0 / live link is in the description
they before would you on over to item
pool which now asks us write a value of
x so that e to the X is equal to I that
way we'll be able to replace it in the
base of our expression and then once we
do that maybe we can use our knowledge
of e and Exponential's of Yi in order to
make some sense out of this expression
now let me just add as a quick reminder
while everyone is rolling in with
answers for that that when we write e to
the X and complex numbers are in the mix
we are no longer talking about repeated
multiplication and instead I think the
healthiest way to think about it is that
e to the X is a shorthand for this
polynomial that I might call X it's the
it's sort of the main exponential
function all other exponential functions
derived from this in a way that I'll
describe later on in in this episode
actually and
it's a lovely polynomial it's one plus X
plus x squared over 2 plus X cubed over
6 each term looks like a power of X
divided by the factorial of that power
so the reason for doing that is then it
can actually make sense to plug in
things like complex values and one of
the things that we looked at earlier in
the series was how if you're plugging in
imaginary values you know let's say I go
over here and I'm gonna plug in I where
I is the square root of negative 1 times
some value theta we can very literally
read off what it means to exponentiate
it in that context for example this very
first term one we might think of as a
vector pointing from zero to one the
next term which is some scaled version
of I well it's a 90 degree rotation of
that first vector scaled a little bit
differently then the next vector is a 90
degree rotation of that scale
differently and depending on what this
value theta equals the way that these
things scale is going to look very
different and it's in general a
difficult thing to think about but it's
at least a sensible thing to think about
right so that when we go to our
expression e to the X and we're going to
start thinking about I and various
complex numbers it makes sense
computationally what it means and then
there's going to be a separate
illustration that I'll pull up in a
moment for how it makes sense in terms
of intuition what it means but first
let's just see how people are doing on
our live quiz finding a value of x so
that e to the X is equal to I now how
have people done here okay so the top
answer is in a sense absolutely correct
you could say by definition the natural
log is the inverse function of
exponentiation so whatever whatever the
answer here is here we should be able to
write it as natural log of I the problem
is that's not really helpful it's not
going to move us forward because if we
if we tried to use that you know we pop
over here and we say instead of writing
I'm gonna write e to the natural log of
I and then I'm going to be raising that
to some kind of power it begs the
question and the only thing I can really
do from here is simplify that down to BI
which sort of gets us nowhere so to move
forward and to think is there a number
some concrete point on the plane that I
can plug in for that we'd want to look
at
I accidentally skipped ahead of my
questions here let me go back
pull up people's answers got a little
excited a little trigger-happy with some
of my clicking around here and the
second most common answer is something
that's gonna actually help us move
forward here which was one half of I
times pi and then that's the same as
what was written what was categorized as
the third most common one one half pi
times I just swapping the two numbers
there and I think yeah I think the one
following that I'm guessing people
either forgot to mention the I but but
let's just let's just write that out and
kind of see where this moves us one-half
I times pi now if you're confused about
where that came from
I think this is a good time to remind
ourselves of Euler's formula and what
it's really saying it's 1/2 pi times I
where again computationally this very
literally means if we plug in PI over 2
for theta here which would be something
like one point five seven or so let me
see if I can I don't think I'll be able
to get it right on the head but
something in the 1.57 range if you were
to play out this whole sum the claim of
saying that e to the PI halves I equals
I is that when you play all of this out
and you add all of the terms together
you're going to get to the top here but
usually this is kind of a complicated
way to think about it people don't want
to pull up this whole polynomial and
imagine the spiraling sum I think it's
helpful just in case you find yourself
doubting the reality of what we're
talking about or the fact that it's
something sensible almost always anytime
that people are thinking about complex
Exponential's instead they find
themselves thinking something like e to
the I times theta they just immediately
know of maybe not immediately but you
come to immediately know of Euler's
formula that it's telling you you walk a
distance theta around the unit circle
which is to say an angle of theta
radians and whatever point you're
sitting at on the complex plane that's
the output so people who knew about this
would say hmm I as a number is also
sitting on the unit circle so I just
have to walk an angle of 90 degrees
pi-halves radians and from here we can
actually move forward and get kind of a
funny-looking answer because that I will
hop to the inside and we'll be looking
at e to the
I haves times I squared I squared is
negative 1 by definition so this looks
like e to the negative PI halves that is
a purely real number you could just plug
that into your calculator and it's
actually around 0.2 or so it's about 1/5
which is weird that you take an
imaginary number and raise it to an
imaginary power and that gets you a real
number maybe it feels a little bit weird
that a and pi have shown up not that
much if we're thinking in terms of
euler's formula and all of that but I
kind of want to go deeper on this one
right I think it's one thing to plug in
some numbers and see what pops out and
there's a couple great videos who have
talked about I to the ice from some of
my favorite channels stand-up math with
Matt Parker he talked about I to the I
did a beautiful job black pin red pin
did another I to the I video truly great
one thing that I try to you know I tried
to do is add something into the mix if
I'm talking about a topic that others
already have and in this case I think
one of the most interesting questions
you can ask before we jump in I mean
there's lots of interesting things about
this expression I to the eye but if
we're seeking intuition thinking about
how I is a 90 degree rotation right
that's the way that it acts when we're
multiplying things on the complex plane
we think of it very intuitively as the
thing that upon multiplication turns
stuff 90 degrees or PI halves radians so
when you look at this expression that I
to the power I equals e to the negative
PI halves it begs the question in what
sense do two 90 degree rotations combine
to make this real number this very
specific real number of e to the
negative PI halves around zero point two
zero seven nine on and on and it's like
those games that sometimes you play with
arithmetic where someone says oh I'll
give you the numbers 1 3 4 & 6 see if
you can combine them in some way with
addition multiplication division to get
some other specific number like 24 in
that case is a particularly fun puzzle
in this case it's kind of like that
style of puzzle on steroids how do we
take the idea of a 90 degree rotation
and combine it with itself twice in some
mathematical sense such that we get out
this number e to the negative PI halves
where's that intuition coming from and
the first step I would say
to remind ourselves of the intuition for
why it is that oil errs formula works
why it is that I can take an expression
like e to the PI halves I and say that
that's the same thing as I you know I
just showed what it means in a very
computational sense what the claim is
with this spiraling sum but that tells
us nothing about why why it would be the
case that this is how things behave now
I've at this point made you know quite a
number of videos on variants of this but
I think the quickest one is to think of
it dynamically somehow so if we take an
expression like e to the I times T and
we're thinking of that as describing a
dynamic you're gonna have a position
that changes over time then what I'll do
is I'm going to start drawing that with
a blue vector and we know as an initial
condition that when we raise e to the 0
that's at 1 so where we are at time T
equals 0 is equal to 1 but let's say
that's all we know right we haven't been
told about Euler's formula or how we
should be thinking about it with circles
or anything like that that's just where
we're starting well one thing we might
know is that e to the X is its own
derivative so if we're thinking of
dynamics here we might ask about the
velocity of our position taking its
derivative and because e to the X is its
own derivative this is quite nice the
outer expression is gonna stay the same
and then the inner expression as we're
applying the chain rule is just I times
T so we multiply the whole outer thing
by I and this gives us a literal way to
read the equation in terms of dynamics
right what we're saying is take whatever
your position vector is if you rotate
that 90 degrees you apply this action of
I that's going to give you the velocity
vector so wherever you're standing draw
a vector from 0 the origin up to where
you are rotate that vector 90 degrees
that gives you your velocity and that's
enough to tell you how to move assuming
you know that where you're starting and
of course we have to draw this out in
the complex plane the fact that we've
rotated 90 degrees already brings us
there and I could draw out a bunch of
different potential position vectors you
know suggestively maybe putting them on
a circle and saying really imagine
yourself sitting at any one of those and
following the rule for this dynamic and
what it will tell you is ok I've got a
sit there rotate my vector 90 degrees
that does
my velocity and it doesn't necessarily
have to be any one of the points on that
circle any point in the plane if you
were following this dynamic you say
rotate that vector 90 degrees which if
we're drawing a vector field we often
scale down and it's all well and good
and here you could phrase this question
without even talking about Exponential's
or complex numbers or anything like that
and in fact I'm going to go back to the
quiz just to really emphasize that
Euler's formula and what it's claiming
and then how we apply it to expressions
like I to the power I is very it's
really intuitive as soon as we're
putting some dynamics into it and we can
ask questions were moved from the idea
of Exponential's that actually have the
same substance in their answers so here
I want you to imagine starting a walk
from the point one zero on the
coordinate plane in such a way that at
all moments your velocity vector is a
90-degree counterclockwise rotation of
the vector drawn from 0 0 the origin up
to where you are after PI halves units
of time where will you be on the plane
okay so kind of think about that think
about that dynamic and where you'll end
up after a little bit of time while you
answer let me see if we have any
questions that have popped in from the
audience no questions at the moment at
least that I see so if ever you do want
to ask go to Twitter use the hashtag
lockdown math those will be forwarded to
me and then sometimes they'll be on the
screen that I can pull up here and that
always makes for a fun time for example
it seems like now we actually have one
which is how about other solutions to
the expression Expo x equals I such as
five PI halves oh I'm so glad you asked
I'm so very glad you asked we will
certainly be talking about that and if
you just if you just hold on for like
one little moment that's exactly what
we're going to get to so I'll keep that
on file for us to pull up in the little
moment but right now while we're just
trying to get intuition around the first
you know there will be multiple answers
the first answer we saw was e to the
negative PI halves let's consider this
lake question so it seems like most of
you correctly said that this would get
you at the coordinates 0 1 it's
essentially walking you a quarter of the
way around I said late question I'm sort
of picturing in my head is a big
circular lake that you're going for a
walk around because when you have this
rule for dynamics where your position
vector rotated by 90 degrees gives you
your velocity vector that is circular
motion because the tangent line to a
circle is always perpendicular to its
radius so this rule of motion
corresponds with walking around a circle
and that's kind of the intuition for
Euler's formula right that you keep
increasing that value of T and this
dynamical rule if e to the I T is going
to behave according to the derivatives
that we expect of a function like e to
the t necessarily walks you around a
circle so in particular when we're
wondering how long does it take to get
to I you would basically say just wait
for an amount of time equal to well
whatever the angle to get up there is PI
halves ok so in this case we're thinking
PI halves let me see if I can get it
exactly on the dot ok 1.57 we're
thinking PI halves is kind of an amount
of time for these dynamics to get you on
the number I and that gives us the first
half of our intuition if we want to go
back to our formula and we're asking in
what sense do two 90-degree rotations
combined to make e to the negative PI
halves once we're thinking of our
dynamics here as each one of your
velocity vectors is a 90-degree rotation
of your position this base I the way
that we're kind of thinking about it
reading it off is something with meaning
rather than just a number is that as a
point on the plane it's where you get
after traveling for PI halves units of
time according to the dynamics of this
expression according to the idea that
your velocity is always a 90 degree
rotation of your position okay so that's
awfully nice and in fact there's already
sort of two different eyes at play here
which or I guess there's three different
eyes at play we have this base which is
describing the 90 degrees that we walk
around the circle we have the eye that's
sitting here which is describing the
rule of rotating your velocity vector 90
degrees but now we're going to introduce
another eye which essentially has this a
of changing what your dynamics are
because as we go from e to the I times T
and instead we you know raise things to
another power of I which I'll just write
with a little caret hi if we take e to
the I T and we alter what that
expression is by raising it to the I
what we get is e to the negative T okay
so we have e to the negative T and if we
try to interpret that with the same sort
of dynamics that we had above in terms
of a velocity and a position what that's
telling us is that the derivative of our
new dynamic e to the negative T is equal
to well now the constant sitting in
front of T is negative one so our chain
rule will have it be negative one times
itself times e to the negative T so
whatever your position is now your
velocity is negative one times itself so
the effect of raising to another power I
it's kind of like we took the dynamics
we looked at every velocity vector and
we said rotate another 90 degrees so
that in this context it would actually
be in the beginning a velocity vector
pointing backwards with one unit so if
you're starting off at the number one
your initial velocity is to walk
straight toward zero and as you walk
even lower if you were sitting at one
half then you would still be walking
toward zero but now your velocity vector
would be negative one times where you
are which is negative one half and what
this means for the actual motion that
this would imply you might kind of
imagine it
I haven't animated this nicely yet or
anything but if you look at this whole
vector field and you ask each one of
those vectors take wherever you are and
rotate another 90 degrees
counterclockwise they would all be
pointed in towards the origin so if you
were to have a little dot move in such a
way that it's velocity always matches
whatever victor it's sitting on top of
what you would end up with is something
where with each time step it kind of
takes a step toward zero and it just
with each of your time steps is walking
toward zero and each step has a size
that gets smaller and smaller as you
actually approach zero and of course in
practice this would be a bunch of
phantasmal steps rather than very
concrete sizing you might be very exact
about it if you wanted and say what
we're looking at is scaling down by some
number just less than one and we're
doing this in different times and then
we're gonna multiply that by however
much time we're waiting and you take
this as a limiting expression that's
just a what we talked about in the
compound interest lecture if you're
curious and it's kind of the standard
way to talk about e to powers is this
sort of limit you could also have that
te living on the inside here instead if
you wanted but now if we think about our
original point I our base what that
meant it was saying look at our dynamics
and it's the point you get to when you
wait PI halves units of time so the
effect of raising to the eye changes our
dynamics in such a way that instead of
walking around a circle we're doing this
kind of exponential decay we're moving
toward zero at a slowing and slowing
rate and the place that you end up after
PI halves units of time will be e to the
negative PI halves around zero point two
zero seven nine so you know that's a
little bit of intuition for in what
sense do two 90-degree rotations combine
to get you this very specific value one
of them changes your dynamics and the
original one came from the idea of
walking PI halves radians so I think
that's kind of satisfying in its own way
because otherwise when you look at the
expression I to the I equals e to the
negative PI halves it's like what does
any of this mean this doesn't correspond
to any you know thing that might see in
the real world but thinking through the
intuitions actually have you thinking
through things like what are the
dynamics of circular motion what are the
dynamics were exponential decay things
that come up in the real world all the
time but there is a potentially more
pressing question which was raised and
let's see if it's still up there well
whoever asked it a little bit earlier
what about other solutions to e to the x
equals I I think that's that's actually
spot-on and in fact let me let me ask
you other people to contribute some
solutions here so let's let's go to our
quiz let me go to question number three
which is going to be very similar to a
question that was already seen which is
to write a value of
other than the one we just saw x equals
PI halves times I so that e to the X
equals I and feel free to be as creative
as you want to try to get an answer that
other people haven't written right just
to really emphasize that there are
actually quite a few different options
here and then in a moment we'll talk
about why there are quite a few options
if it's not already clear but I'll give
you a moment to think of which of the
many possible values of X you could
choose is the one that you want to put
your fingerprint on that you want to be
contributing to the live stats page that
we're seeing right now I'll give you a
little moment
and as you're answering that we've got a
question coming in that says wouldn't it
be more accurate to say that I to the
power I is I different 90-degree
rotations not two 90-degree rotations
after all it's multiplying by I that's
the rotation so if we stretch the
meaning of words too thin aren't we
multiplying by I I times I mean I think
the most honest answer here is just no
not at all
no offense meant but that's just not
what exponentiation actually means as
soon as we're extending to the idea of
complex numbers i I get the intent you
kind of want to stretch the meaning of
taking I to the I it's as if you're
multiplying by itself I different times
but I I cannot think of a way that that
actually like satisfactorily makes sense
in my mind what I do think makes some
sense is to try to think of the function
I to the X say what properties do we
want this function to have and in the
context of counting numbers you know if
N and K are just things like 3 & 5 we
know that it should satisfy this idea of
multiplying the outputs correspond to
adding the inputs so we want to say if
this is any kind of function and you
know I've said this in many different
forms in many different places we want
it to satisfy the property that when you
add the inputs you multiply the outputs
that to me is kind of what
exponentiation is moreso than trying to
stretch the idea of repeated
multiplication so it like if it I mean
correct me if I'm wrong if you can
definitely if you can find some way
where if you would read this off in a
stretching language context saying we're
taking a 90 degree rotation and applying
that I different times
that's not nonsense and that somehow
like intuitively gets you to the answer
e to the negative PI halves I'm all ears
but I think the healthier relationship
to have is to say we have this central
property for exponentiation
which definitely holds in the context of
repeated multiplication but to extend
beyond the places where repeated
multiplication makes any sense because
it just it just doesn't make sense when
we're talking about something that's not
a counting number like I or other crazy
things that we exponentiate
like matrices focus focus on the
property moreso than what some people
think of as the origins of that property
or the original intuition behind it
an interesting question will be you know
is is there just one such function that
feels reasonable to write for this
because you know if we're gonna write it
as I to the X not only should it satisfy
this it should also satisfy you know
when we plug in the number one we get I
presumably I to the power one however
we're thinking of this function should
be I is there just one such function or
are there multiple such functions that's
what the quiz question is starting to
get at and we've got lots of different
answers which always makes me happy so
let's see some of the variety now that
people have thrown in here so we've got
five PI halves great that absolutely is
another value that we can plug in for X
here and just to spell out that a little
bit more visually if we were to look
back at our circle here where we've at
the moment walked for an amount of time
equal to PI halves which is one point
five seven what if instead we took
another full turn and we go another PI
halves to get us to pi which you know we
might kind of record that's where the e
to the PI I value is we walk another PI
halves we walk another pi halves which
at this point we will be gone a full
circle getting us back to one and then
we walk four five PI halves which
numerically is about seven point eight
five yeah that absolutely is another
number that gets us on top of I and if
we were to go through the whole
rigmarole of re expressing I to the
power I by first writing e to the five
PI halves I to the power I those eyes
multiply to become negative and we'd be
looking at e to the negative 5 PI halves
which is a very different number right
we can actually calculate this I'm not
sure off the top of my head but let's
take a look at a des most maybe go over
here let's ask it what is e to the
negative 5 PI halves zero point zero
zero zero three eight eight okay zero
zero zero three eight eight much smaller
number
zero zero zero three eight eight which
begs the question of okay eye to the eye
what are you right are you about a fifth
like we saw before around 0.2 or are you
this much smaller number and in terms of
our intuition it's basically a a
question of how we're interpreting that
base eye right
are we thinking of it as you wait about
one point five seven units of time and
then you translate your dynamics into
something that looks like decay rather
than spinning and see where you decay to
after that amount of time which is 0.2
or do you wait even longer for about
seven point eight five units of time
which is five PI halves and what see
what happens when you decay for that
long which gets you to a much smaller
number but that's not the only answer
that we could enter right we have other
people coming in here with negative
three-halves times i pi which you know
in terms of a unit circle we could think
of as saying hey if i want to get to i
rather than walking ninety degrees PI
halves radians that way what if I walk
270 degrees the other way three PI
halves radians which maybe I'll think of
as negative because the convention is
usually the counterclockwise is positive
that absolutely is another way to
express it and that would give us a
different answer if we had e to the
negative three PI halves I all for the
power I we go through the same game now
the I squared cancels with a negative
that's already there and we have a
positive three PI halves and numerically
this gets us an even different looking
answer from what we had before which if
we go over and we say hey what is e to
the three PI not three oh three PI
halves a hundred and eleven point three
one very different kind of number than
what we saw before one hundred and
eleven point what was it one hundred
eleven point three one gate had an
eleven point three one or so and again
in terms of the intuition well you might
be asking there is suppose we have this
rotating dynamic but we move backwards
in time we see how long ago in time
would I have to be such that if I played
things forward from there
I would land on the
number one my initial condition and you
have to go back in time three PI halves
units and then if you were to translate
to the decay dynamics which is what
raising to the AI is doing in this
context you say if I'm starting at the
number one but I want to move backwards
in time and say where should I have
started if I want to decay down such
that I end up at the number one after
three PI halves units of time the answer
is evidently starting at around a
hundred and eleven for that kind of
exponential decay and you can see where
this is going where there's actually
infinitely many different values that we
could plug in for X if we're thinking of
e to the X as being I and people have
entered a lot more here
excuse me throwing my pin onto the
ground as one does classic for third
place nine PI halves great choice
17:29 PI halves y'all are my favorite
lots and lots of different options
infinitely many different values which
feels a little disconcerting at first
right because we look at an expression
that seems like you know there's just
gonna be some computation I just plug
that into my calculator and see what
pops out and we've got multiple
different values for it so what's going
on here right what's going on and I
think this really cuts to the idea of
how we think about Exponential's in
general right but before that I do want
to emphasize that this isn't the only
time in math where we come across a kind
of ambiguity for how to interpret
something because if I say something
like what is the square root of 25 you
know I think a lot of us say well it's 5
but if we are saying you know what
should the square root be it should be
some number X such that when you square
it you get 25 well there's two different
answers to that who's to say that our
conventions should be that the square
root function is positive gives us a
positive number rather than negative 5
so we have one expression that seems
like it wants to have multiple different
values right and this could actually
happen in another context where instead
of square roots what if I was asking for
the fourth root of something like 16
usually we would think of this as
positive number two right 2 is a number
such that when you multiply by itself
four times you get 16 seems like a
decent answer to a fourth root but if
we're thinking of this as answering the
question what number
the fourth equals 16 there there is
another answer to this we could also say
negative 2 that's a number that when you
multiply by itself four times you get 16
but there's another answer you could say
two times I that seems valid but there's
another answer you could think negative
two times I all four of these numbers
satisfy that property so who's to say
that the fourth root of 16 should be two
and the answer ends up being well we
adopted convention when there's multiple
options like this when you have a multi
valued function we often just choose one
of those values to be what we mean when
we want to treat it as a function as
something with a single input and a
single output in fancier lingo
this comes up all the time when we're
dealing with complex numbers the idea of
something as an operation kind of
wanting to have multiple values you'll
sometimes hear the phrase branch where
you choose a branch of the square root
function which is to say you choose a
certain convention and real numbers it's
nice and easy sometimes because you say
just choose the positive one but there's
no notion of which complex members are
like the positive complex numbers when
we want to take square roots just to
give one example let's say we wanted to
take the square root of I and we want to
know what should that be because there's
multiple different answers you know we
think of I again as this 90 90 degree
rotation and if we were thinking of it
as a 90 degree rotation it feels like
the square root should be you know
something sitting at a 45 degree angle
maybe that's the square root of I which
we could write out very explicitly as
root 2 over 2 root 2 over 2 I that's
just using trigonometry but if we were
thinking of I instead as being a
negative 270 degree rotation it feels
like half of that doing half of that
operation should actually get us on the
other side maybe the number sitting down
here should be the square root of I and
that's actually just the negative of
what we saw before negative root 2 over
2 minus root 2 over 2 times I now in the
context of real valued functions we can
say yeah just choose the square root to
be whatever the positive answer is but
which of these do you consider the
positive answer you know maybe it feels
like
we should can consider this upper one
because it's coordinates have positive
numbers but however you try to define
positive in a nice way here that's going
to be consistent you know for example
two positive numbers should always
multiply to make a positive number
you're not really going to be able to do
it the way that you can for real numbers
and in fact this phenomenon here where
we're taking roots it's actually the
same as the phenomenon we were just
looking at when we were talking about
multiple values for I raised to the
power of I because forget I raised to
the power of I let me ask what much
might look like it's a much simpler
question of taking two to the power
one-half okay
what's 2 to the one-half yeah I think
you say well we know what this is we
kind of define it to be the square root
of 2 all is well and good but what if I
said let's approach this the same way
that we were approaching our eye to the
eye expression I want to first express
things as e to the something right and
then I'm going to raise that to the 1/2
by multiplying the 1/2 into the exponent
and I'd say okay I can I guess I can do
that e to the what is equal to 2 well
that's the natural log of 2 it's a
constant which is around zero point six
nine or so if we raise e to that power
we'll get to so we could be thinking of
this as e to the natural log of 2 times
one-half and if you wanted to if you
were thinking of e to the X you know
this might be kind of overkill in the
context of real numbers but if you were
thinking of e to the X as shorthand for
this X function you could plug in the
value zero point six nine times one half
which I guess would be around zero point
three four five is something like that
you plug in that very concrete value
into your polynomial see what it outputs
and it will output around one point four
one for a nice real number it's square
root of two what you would expect but if
we do the same thing we were just doing
with I and acknowledging that there's
actually multiple different answers when
we want to write something as e to a
power we could also write this this
might seem funny but we could write it
as e to the natural log of 2 plus 2 pi I
that whole thing raised to the one-half
right after all this value will come to
equal to you could break it down as it's
e to the natural log of 2 multiplied by
e to the 2 pi this one just has the
effect of rotating things 360 degrees so
it's just going to equal one so we're
looking at two times one great that
feels like a valid substitution and yet
when we play the same game of taking
this and raising it to a power and
treating that by multiplying the power
into the exponent look at what happens
we have e to the natural log of 2 times
1/2 plus well what's 2 pi I times 1/2
well that will be pi times I now this
first part e to the natural log of 2
times 1/2 that will end up being the
familiar square root of 2 that's all
well and good but we're going to be
multiplying that by e to the PI I right
and quite famously e to the PI I is
negative 1 so in this case it seems to
be suggesting that if we are solving
this expression 2 to the 1/2 by playing
around with the different answers we
could plug in for something like e to
the X equaling 1/2 what we end up with
is another answer what we might
traditionally write as this negative
square root of 2 and here I mean it's a
little funny for it to have multiple
values to look at 2 to the 1/2 and say
that's not equaling one thing but based
on choices we make it could equal
multiple different things but the two
things that it could seem quite
reasonable if there's going to be
anything that 2 to the one-half is it
seems like it should either be the
positive square root that we're familiar
with or the negative variant of that
that doesn't actually seem like such a
problem and in fact we could um we could
play this game even further where let me
ask you for even more creative answers
to this expression because maybe we can
find other funny powers of something
like 2 to the power X as we start
plugging in various different values of
X based on what substitution we make if
we're abiding by the same rules that we
were using in evaluating I to the power
I so this time the question asks or it
specifies that one solution of the
equation e to the x equals 2 is the real
number natural log of 2 u ok
that one we know it it's not boring but
it's boring in comparison to what else
we can do can you think of another one
and can you write some other answer to
the question e to the x equals 2 and
again creativity is welcomed so I will
give you another little moment for that
all right I will go ahead and walk in
some answers here if that's all right
with you I'm not sure how much time it
necessarily takes to do the math entry
depending on what device you're looking
at but don't be too stressed if it's
before you got the chance to into the
question that you want into the answer
that you want it to answer so it looks
like 131 of you have entered the variant
where we take Ln of 2 and we add 2 hyah
and I guess I am in writing this
question mistakenly like marked one of
the answers as being correct when in
fact there's quite a few different
correct ones
so that's on me for the fact that I
don't know if it looks to any of you
like oh it's red you got it wrong when
you entered Ln of 2 plus 42 I pi which
is of course a great choice but you
could also have something like 4 pi plus
the natural log of 2 or 6 pi I or really
any integer multiple of 2 pi I if you
add that it doesn't affect e to the X
because it just has the effect of
multiplying by e to the 2 pi which is
the effect of multiplying by 1 and again
this has kind of a funny consequence
where it seems to output kind of
reasonable results when we do it as
another example it looks like the second
most common entered expression there was
that we might replace 2 so let's think
we're thinking 2 to the power of one
fourth okay there was a suggestion that
we replaced 2 with e to the natural log
of 2 plus 4 PI I okay plus 4 PI and we
raise all of that to the 1/4 all right
well if you were to play the same game
you would get e to the natural log of 2
times 1/4 and we'd be multiplying by e
to the PI I now the first part of that
is going to be the usual positive 4th
root of 2 the thing we mean when you
plug in an expression like 4th root of 2
into a calculator a nice small positive
number but then this second part is
negative 1 so it seems to be saying you
know if we returned her for 2 in this
different way raising it to the 1/4 you
know it's not the usual answer that we
get but it's a reasonable answer it's
another number that when you raise it to
the fourth power you get 2
and if we had done this with even
different values if instead we had been
using two pi you know it's kind of fun
to think about how that would have
changed things if instead of four pi we
had been adding two pi
well then over here we would have been
looking at PI halves times I and instead
of multiplying by negative one we would
have instead been multiplying by I which
again is a valid answer that seems like
a reasonable output for something like
two to the one-fourth so when you're
looking at the fact that I to the power
I seems to have multiple different
values for it right we have this funny
phenomenon where we can plug in e to the
five PI halves I negative three PI
halves I and we get what seemed like
wildly different answers something super
small something super big all very
different from the 1/5 approximately 1/5
answer that we found before up here it's
exactly the same phenomenon as when
you're asking something like what's 2 to
the 1/4 and acknowledging that there's
actually multiple different solutions to
the expression X to the 4th equals 2 for
different solutions in fact and what
you're looking at is the fact that
there's multiple different solutions to
the expression e to the x equals some
kind of base whether that base is I
whether that base is 2 whatever it might
be and one way that we might think about
this is that we're dealing with real
numbers
things are just lovely things are nice
there's one-to-one relationships you've
got positives it's great where if we
want to think about exponential
functions let me just cover some of this
stuff up
we have this nice back and forth where
you can choose to express any
exponential as a base to X like 2 to the
X or you could express that same
exponential as X of R times X which you
know that is the polynomial that we
refer to whenever implicitly referred to
whenever we write something like e to
the X and these are lovely back and
forth because you can just take a
natural logarithm of B and it gives you
one answer assuming that B is a positive
number and that's the same thing as
saying that X bar is equal to B so one
way that I've talked about this earlier
in the series is that if you were
looking at the family of all possible
Exponential's
and we could write them as X both are
times X and change what R is and this is
exactly the same thing as writing e to
the R times X if that's something you're
more comfortable with so e to the R
times X X pivara times X those are the
same thing we could think about changing
what that is but on the other hand if
you were to think about all possible
Exponential's as some base let me do
base for the power of X and we're going
to change what that base is at first it
feels like that's a different kind of
expression to manipulate but it's just
another way of expressing the same
family and a way that you might think
about this for how do we think about
what base does it correspond to if we're
thinking a little bit more abstractly as
X part times X and there's a reason I'm
doing this because we're about to apply
this to complex numbers where it's going
to look weird er so follow through with
me here if instead of looking at that
base one thing I could do is say what is
the value of x both are right which is
basically this function but when we plug
in one so X bar times one if you prefer
to think of it that way and that is
being represented by our Green Line and
what you can see is okay if I get R that
factor in front of X in my exponential
function X bar X to be zero point six
nine which I know is around the natural
log of two what this means is that X
both 1 is about 2 and so this
corresponds with the function that we
would usually write as 2 to the power X
right okay and basically as I change
around my our you know I could try to
change it to something so that it looks
like 3 so around 1.1 that exponential
looks like 3 which we would usually
write as 3 to the power X I would like
to argue that it's a little bit
healthier to think about varying this
value R rather than varying the base and
the main reason is that as soon as we
get to complex contacts and we're
thinking of exponentiation you have this
overloading that goes on where if you
change around what sits in front of the
X that's all well and good I could have
X above R times X where maybe are
something like zero point 6 9 but I
could shift that down by 2 pi I and that
doesn't change the base that it would
correspond
that would still correspond to two or it
could shift it up by 2 pi that doesn't
change the base that it corresponds to
because in all of those cases when we
plug in x equals 1 we get the same thing
however all of these for different
values of X are distinct functions this
is why we saw multiple different values
for I to the power I because I to the X
is an ambiguous function in that context
it would be unambiguous if we decided
which value of R such that what we're
representing is X of R times X which
value of R do we choose as soon as we
choose one it's an unambiguous function
but at that point it just feels like
maybe what we want is a to stop thinking
about things in terms of some base
raised to the power X maybe as soon as
we're in the context of complex numbers
we should just write them all as X of
some constant times X if for no other
reason it makes crystal clear how we
actually plug in numbers if we want to
do a computation or just to do math on
top of it we've got this nice infinite
polynomial that we plug them into and
I'll make another case for you that this
is this is maybe the the correct way to
think about Exponential's as soon as
we're extending into other domains
things like complex numbers and for that
let's just let's just back up go back to
Oh doorbell something's arrived go back
to the original way that we extend the
idea of exponentiation and just think of
like what is 2 to the X we know how to
think about this for natural numbers you
have something like 2 to the 3 repeated
multiplication how is it that you're
first taught to think about something
like 2 to the X for fractional amounts
or for negative amounts and things like
that
well you're usually taught that 2 to the
1/2 should be something where you know
if I multiply it by itself and this
follows the usual rules that
Exponential's do with counting numbers
where we're able to add things in that
exponent I should get 2 to the 1 so it
should be some number that when I
multiply it by itself I get 2 and you
know at that point you have a choice
maybe it's positive maybe it's negative
but if you always decide to make the
positive choice you're going to be able
to get a nice continuous function out of
this same deal if we asked about
negative numbers what should 2 to the
name
one be well that should be something
where when I multiply it by two to the
one it gets me two to the zero and
that's kind of the justification for our
convention that negative exponents look
like one half but what's really going on
here is we're saying whatever this is it
should be some kind of function that
satisfies this property f of a plus B
equals F of a times F of B and moreover
the fact that the base is 2 is basically
telling us that it's not just any such
function it's a function where when we
plug in 1 we get 2 and just as a little
you know sanity check style question to
see if you're following along with some
of the implications here I want to ask
you what is I'm gonna call it like a
softball but this is this isn't meant to
be like an incredibly deep question
necessarily it's just more of a check if
you're following along with the idea of
abstractly starting with properties of a
function and then kind of deducing ways
that we might want to write it down
based on those properties if f of X
satisfies this exponential property f of
a plus B equals F of a times f of B for
all inputs and it also satisfies F of 1
equals 2 which of the following is true
which is to say which of the following
is necessarily true no matter which such
function you're starting with and those
of you who remember which lecture was it
it's whichever one we were talking about
how to enter what Euler's formula is
really saying I asked a question of this
style where I neglected a single
condition you know I didn't write down
the fact that we want to make sure f of
X is nonzero everywhere and then that
caused some amount of confident which is
cool could come follow mint on screen
that happens to all of us but the the
intent of it was to basically show that
this abstract property have something
that turns addition into multiplication
is
it is enough to basically make you want
to write the function as whatever it
equals is 1 raised to some kind of power
this is the the spirit of the question
now we've got a couple questions
actually about power towers that seem to
have popped up here which is great
connected to last time let's let's hold
off on the power tower question for just
a moment so that we first get like a
deeper feel of like what exponentiation
should mean here because because we can
be what I want to claim is we can answer
it in like multiple different ways so if
you give me just one we'll talk about
power towers and then just as a number
line can be represented in a logarithmic
scale can the same done be done for a
complex plane maybe mapping the complex
plane onto an infinite cylinder in the
logarithmic sense yeah yeah in fact
there's a visualization that I'm going
to get to in just a moment here where we
do something quite similar to that
because what we'll do is play around
with different exponential functions X
bar times X but we're going to change
that value of R which is going to be
represented by a little yellow dot so
we'll kind of talk through this it's not
going to map the whole plane but just a
couple sample points from the real axis
and the imaginary axis but the idea is
that as we move around what that
constant is we're going to be able to
kind of visualize the different things
that it does to the plane and
effectively it's like it's turning the x
axis into a logarithmic scale and then
wrapping the imaginary axis along a
circle and then as soon as that value of
R becomes imaginary it swaps the role of
those real numbers get put on the circle
and imaginary numbers get put on a
logarithmic scale positive axis so great
question all three of which I guess are
sort of jumping the gun ahead for where
I want to go but nice to see that's
where people are thinking so on this one
let's go ahead and just create it the
idea is that this this property of f of
a plus B ends up letting you express a
lot of different things purely in terms
of what F of 1 is and just to spell that
out very explicitly something like f of
5 is the same thing as F of 1 plus 1
plus 1 plus 1 plus 1
which is the same thing as f of 1
multiplied by itself 5 times because of
this property which if F of 1 is 2 is
the same as 2 to the power 5 and then
something like F of negative 5 it should
be the case that when we multiply it by
F of 5 we get whatever F of 0 is and
it's not immediately clear what F of 0
is but we could say that F of 1 plus 0
is equal to whatever F of 1 is times
what F of 0 is but F of 1 is equal to 2
and so this is also equal to 2 so we're
saying 2 is equal to 2 times something
well that something has to be a 1 so in
this context this guarantees that F of
negative 5 is 2 to the negative 5 it's 1
over 2 to the fifth so we can explicitly
write this as 2 to the negative 5 which
is all to say these two properties
together make us really want to write
the function as 2 to the X because any
counting number that we put in it's
going to satisfy it's it's going to look
like 2 multiplied by itself that number
of times any fractional number we put in
it's going to satisfy these properties
that we wanted and you might wonder is
that unique and in the context of real
valued functions it actually would be
but in the context of complex valued
functions there would be multiple such
functions f that we could write for this
one of which is what we were looking at
before where we could have a function
defined to be X of the natural log of 2
plus 2 pi all of that times X ok forgive
the sloppiness here I just get excited
writing about this and this is actually
a different function as evidenced by
what happens if you plug in x equals 1/2
we saw a little bit earlier how when you
plug in 1/2 what you get is the negative
square root of 2 and then if you plug in
1/4 you get not the fourth root of 2 but
I times the fourth root of 2 so it is a
different function but it still
satisfies these properties and it kind
of makes us want to write it as 2 to the
X and it makes it suggests that maybe 2
to the X is an ambiguous bit of notation
and we should just write everything
in terms of X of our times something but
you might wonder well you know maybe
we're just not being creative enough
with all of the functions that satisfy
this property maybe there's an ambiguity
when we write X bar times something and
there's different values of R that could
come into play but I'm just going to put
down a little claim and then maybe give
like a sketch of what the proof would
look like if you want which is that
let's say you have some complex function
f and it satisfies the following
properties first you're able to take a
derivative of it it's differentiable
which just keeps it from being some you
know totally messy discontinuous thing
that's like taking on some random values
depending on you know the span of
whatever vector space over
I don't know fractional amounts you
might want to think of in crazy ways
it's a nice function that's
differentiable it's not equal to zero
everywhere so the condition that sort of
slipped my mind and I forget which
lecture lecture four or something like
that
and then it has this central property
that it turns addition into
multiplication if you have such a
function I claim that there is a unique
maybe have to really specify there exist
a unique complex number R so that you
could write f of X as basically being
this exponential function of R times
that value X which is you know basically
saying that if you have expose a
function this infinite polynomial with
nice derivative properties and all of
that if you have this you have every
exponential that you want in a very like
abstract generic sense of the word
exponential just based on a property
that we could want from it and the
sketch of the proof would look something
like this if you want to first look at
what is the derivative of this value
which we're assuming exists everywhere
and and you explicitly write out what
the limit of that is I'll just talk to
her very quickly here for those who want
to like pause and think through the
details feel free to the central
property that we have lets us expand out
the f of X plus h term so we're thinking
you know a change slight change to the
output over the change to the input that
cost it that's what DF DX unwraps to and
because we can factor that out we can
factor f of X out of the expression
entirely and the whole limit is
only in terms of H which if you think
about what it means in the context of
derivatives and the fact that F of 0
necessarily equals 1
this whole limiting expression is just
some constant but more specifically it's
whatever the derivative of our function
at 0 is so you have this funny thing
where if you know it's derivative at 0
that determines what its derivative is
everywhere and in the context of
exponential functions this is hopefully
quite familiar because all with all that
we're really saying is the derivative of
an exponential function is proportional
to itself and that proportionality
constant is equal to whatever the
derivative at 0 is this is all very
abstractly phrased and such but but the
purpose of it is to emphasize that it's
not necessarily just functions that we
already think of as a to the power X but
it is a potentially much more broad
class of functions that to satisfy this
abstract property of turning addition
into multiplication but if you have that
it actually guarantees that you also
have a second derivative and for that
matter a third derivative and such
because the derivative function is just
proportional to itself so in order to
take the nth derivative you just look at
that proportionality constant and raise
it to the power N and then from here you
could do a Taylor series expansion and I
might leave that as sort of the advanced
homework for those of you who are
comfortable with Taylor series and that
idea especially if you want to intermix
the idea of any differentiable function
that's differentiable in a sense of
complex numbers which is sort of a
definitely college topic you know you
you you you could intermix the reasoning
there as you want but fuzzy reasoning is
allowed in the context of someone who
only knows about Taylor series and
nothing else to take this idea and look
at the Taylor expansion for F and kind
of justify the idea that there's a
unique complex number such that our
function f can necessarily be written
like this
and then the connection to normal
Exponential's is whenever you have such
a value R we do essentially what we do
in the complex context of real numbers
is if you look at expo that function f
that value R and write that as a base it
feels like you should be able to write
that as B to the X
but the whole the whole point here of
course is that when we play this game
and you're trying to interpret something
like I to the X that's an ambiguous
function because there's lots of
different values of R we can interpret
that to mean not just X both PI halves I
times X but we could also interpret it
to mean expo of five PI halves I times X
and these are separate functions and
there's an infinite family of separate
functions that feel like we should write
them as I'd to the X so the expression I
to the I unless you've adopted a
standard for what that's necessarily
going to mean when you say it has
infinitely many outputs another way to
think of that is that the function I to
the X with the notation we have is a
little bit ambiguous now with all of
that let's let's just start visualizing
some of this because I think that's fun
and you know you you tell me if this is
if this is a helpful visual or a more
confusing visual but what we're going to
do is look at this function X bar times
X which is basically this is another way
to write e to the power of X in fact I
think I I think I rendered a different
animation at some point that specified
that because I was planning on planning
on doing that
so let me oh yeah there you are get back
in my file system get back to where
you're supposed to be get on in there is
a complaining because there's multiple
different it's gonna be like there's a
oh replace it shows up on the other
screen wait why is it ok place place
whatever you see there and now we go
back to all of that all of that just so
that I could have nicely written out if
you're uncomfortable we're thinking of
it as X of R times X this infinite
polynomial just in the back of your head
e to the R times X and we're gonna vary
around R so I'm going to follow the
points of the imaginary axis and I'm
gonna follow the points of the real axis
and let's see what this does
well that's all kind of fast so let me
think through it a little bit more
slowly all of the negative numbers
anything that's a negative real number
is going to get squished into the range
between 0 and 1 which would make sense e
to the negative B to a negative real
number is
thing between 0 & 1 and we're
specifically tracking F of negative 1
which is going to show up around
whatever 1 over E is around 30 0.37 F of
1 lands on e as expected that's what X
both 1 is f of I is going to land a 1
Radian around the unit circle and it's
kind of fun to follow along the whole
imaginary axis here how the imaginary
axis gets wrapped around a circle and
what happens as we tweak this value of R
that's determining not just that we're
talking about an exponential function
but which exponential function there's a
nice one to one correspondence between
all the exponential functions we might
want and values of R here it stretches
things differently so when we put it up
to two you know it stretches out the
real axis a lot more so that f of one
ends up around where Y squared is a
little above seven f of negative one is
much closer to 0 F of I is a two Radian
rotation around the circle F of negative
I is a negative two Radian rotation and
of course we can get to our favorite
formula that if that were pi that we had
as our scaling constant then the real
axis gets stretched out quite a lot you
know F of 1 is sitting off at e to the
PI which is very close to 20 plus pi
which is always fun and F of negative 1
extremely close to zero so it's really
stretched out that real axis and it's
also stretched out things in the unit
circle direction so that getting to F of
I or F of negative I walks halfway
around the circle so that's all well and
good now how would we think about a
function like 2 to the X which is what
we would also write as X of X above the
natural log of 2 times X so if we kind
of move our yellow dot representing the
value of R to around 0.69 still no
imaginary part just a real number zero
point 6 9 or so that's the natural log
of 2 well you can see that F of 1 lands
on 2 which is why we want to call this
function 2 to the X F of 1/2 actually
sorry F of negative 1 lands right on 1/2
F of I it's some walk around the unit
circle very specifically it's going to
be 0.6 9 radians around the unit circle
and now we could have a little bit more
fun and say
what would happen if we were to change
this to instead of being 0.69 instead of
being the natural log of to make it I
times the natural log of two so that
we're really thinking of something that
might have an exponential base to it
this would be what we might think of as
two times I raised to a power well if we
move that yellow dot which is
representing our off of the real axis
and on to the imaginary axis it swaps
the roles of the teal dots and all of
the maroon dots in this context which
remember came from being the positive
and imaginary axes and it should make
sense that it swaps their roles because
what does it mean if we take the input
space and we multiply it by I
it means we're rotating that input space
so everything that was the real number
axis turns into the imaginary axis and
everything that was the imaginary axis
is getting turned into the real axis so
for us what that means is our new
exponential function where our value of
R is now purely imaginary takes all of
the real numbers and it just wraps them
around a circle and it takes all the
imaginary numbers and it's putting them
onto the real number line so in
particular let's say we scale this thing
up so that we're sitting at around PI
halves times I well what does that
actually mean that means it takes the
real number 1 to the value I which is
the sense in which we want to write this
function as I to the power X right it
just tempts us to write it not as this
abstract looking thing X bar times X
where R is equal to PI halves I know no
we just want to write it as I to the X
even if that's a little ambiguous what
that really means it's just that the
function we're dealing with outputs I at
1 and if it's an exponential function
that and we're asking what does it do to
the value I what is I to the power I in
this case it shoves it to around 0.2
around 1/5 but there's many different
exponential functions that would have
this property of putting F of 1 onto the
number I so if we were to scale it up
even further I don't think I haven't
animated here but if we were to take
that yellow dot and raise it up until it
got to 5 halves times pi I what you
would see is that the unit circle is
rotated around on itself so that F of
negative 1 would rotate around another 2
pi radians and land
where it is but it would stretch out the
real axis a lot more which was the sense
in which another output of eye to the
eye is a much much smaller number
it was around what was it 0.0003 or so
but we can also see what I think is
quite fun what happens if we consider
alternate expressions that we want to
interpret as two to the power X right so
when R is a purely real number the
natural log of two kind of makes sense
that when you plug it in here the
expression we get is what we want to
write as 2 to the power X but what if we
start moving it in the imaginary
direction ok and what I'll first do is
I'll move it up by PI I units now what's
going on here we have X bar times X and
R is equal to this value which is the
natural log of 2 plus pi times I what
that means is that when we plug in 1 f
of 1 is that negative 2 so we want to
write this function as negative 2 to the
power X right and that's actually
something that you know it's it's a
little deceptively simple when we write
a negative number to a power negative 2
to the power X it doesn't at first look
like this necessarily it brings us into
the complex numbers in any way but of
course when we plug in even a value like
1/2 where we're kind of asking for a
square root of negative 2 we realize
that we want to write this as something
like I times the square root of 2 but if
you were to look at this function
negative 2 to the power X in the full
complex domain that is dealing with what
you're looking at is a function that
takes the value of 1 to negative 2 and
if it does that what it does to the rest
of the real number line is it kind of
spirals it outward so we see that F of
negative 1 sits at negative 1/2 about
where you would expect if you were to
follow to F of 1/2 it would sit exactly
on the imaginary line and F of 1/2 would
be square root of 2 all my Mouse's not
where I want it to be it would be around
a square root of 2 times I and as you
continue further on this is showing you
all of the real value powers of negative
2 to the X it necessarily spirals around
but we could also move our value of R
even higher and get it up to around
cow times I around six point two eight
times I and in that context this is
another function that we would want to
write as something like two to the X
because for any hole number two hole
number that you plug in for X it will
look like repeated multiplication and it
even has kind of reasonable values for
things like 1/2 where it spits out the
negative square root instead of positive
square root but what it's actually doing
is a transformation to the plane where
it puts everything is the real number
line ends up being a very tightly wound
spiral that goes around and it just
spirals in such a way that f of one
lands right on the number two so it is
in that sense that we could say two to
the X is is plausibly interpreted as a
separate exponential function from the
one that we are traditionally used to so
I think with all of that I will I will
leave things for today and I'll just
leave you with a couple lingering
questions to think about ok so if you
want to think of eye to the eye as being
a multivalued expression right you could
you could say we adopt a convention
fancifully you'd say you choose a branch
of the natural logarithm function and
maybe that locks you into this being e
to the negative PI halves but if you say
this kind of wants to be infinitely many
different values like the various ones
that we saw how many values does 2 to
the 1/3 want to be in the same sense
where we are replacing 2 with various
different various different options for
e to the X such that e to the x equals 2
how many different values does that want
to be or how many values does 2 to the
3/10
want to be phrased differently of all of
the let me say of all of the exponential
functions f of X which satisfy Oh have I
written it down somewhere f of X that
satisfies all of these properties that
I've written so if it satisfies all of
these and if f of 1 is equal to 2 all
right how many different outputs are we
going to get when we plug in x equals
3/10 for the various options for what
function that is and how many outputs
are we going to get for 2 to the PI for
the
functions the two to the X could
represent if we're thinking of two to
the X as some kind of exponential
function exponential in the sense of
these sort of abstract properties and if
we yeah if we if we have a class of
different such functions and we want to
plug in PI it makes me laugh just
because it's such a and a kind of a
funny answer that pops out as you're
trying to think about it so those are
the questions that I'll leave you with
and I think this is you know my my
central question in approaching today's
lecture was whether I wanted it to be
kind of describing like these abstract
properties of exponential functions and
it's just cool to me that starting from
those abstract properties you get locked
into the idea of e to the rx or more jet
you know I think more honestly but an X
of R times X for different values of R
that it locks you in that far but it
doesn't lock you in as far as having an
unambiguous notion of what 2 to the
power X should be much less something
like I to the power X the risk in that
of course is that sometimes people don't
love abstraction and sometimes it
doesn't come off as approachable but if
that's the case you know you just let me
know I think I think there's a whole
interesting circle of thoughts that
surrounds all of this stuff to include
power towers because if you want to
actually talk about power towers like we
were last time in the context of complex
numbers or even with negative bases you
have to be thinking through things like
this so it was a question that we had up
on screen yeah what happens if we do
this for I to the power I tetration you
know let's just try this let's just go
ahead and try a power tower where we're
raising I to a given power and see what
what pops out of it so I wasn't planning
on doing this but we can we can always
pull up Python and essentially do what
we were doing last time so the way that
this would work is we were starting off
with some base value and then for some
kind of range what were we doing we were
taking a and we're going to reassign it
to be whatever the base which in this
case is I raised to the power of a
should be okay cool so we're going to do
that and then we're going to print off
the value of a and let's just do this
for yeah it's a much bigger number
like 200 so it seems like what happens
is there's there's potential for chaos
but these things like sometimes it's not
that you've landed on a stable a stable
value or it's not even that you've
diverged it could be that you're
bouncing between a cycle of values or
that you're like literally bouncing in a
way that's it's not periodic or anything
and it's actually chaotic I that doesn't
happen for I but it's a thing to
potentially look out for it looks like
it does kind of stabilize maybe there's
some little subjection to numerical
error but we stay pretty consistently
around something with a real part of 0.4
3 and 0.36 now what I would want to
emphasize though is this expression so
let's set a back to be equal to 1 this
expression of taking I to the power of a
remember that's a little bit ambiguous
it depends on what choice of the
function I we actually have so let me
let me import numpy so I have the
exponential function let me go for our
big range like we had before rather than
writing it as you know something that's
like I to the power of X I'm gonna write
it as the exponential function of a
different constant write a different
constant that I'm gonna make I want it
to be 5 PI halves so I'll do five PI
halves times I so it's a complex number
and it's got five PI halves as the
imaginary part so this is five PI halves
times I and what am i doing I'm
exponentiating that so I want to
multiply a onto the inside there okay
this is basically another way that you
could interpret the expression I to the
X ffensive LY you would say you've
chosen a different branch of the natural
log function but it is another function
which we could iterate on itself and see
what happens and we might get a
different result
I'm very interesting okay so we actually
have a different result it looks like
what ends up happening is it bounces
between two values oh wow is it Period
three that's interesting period three
implies chaos so we've got seven point
three five and zero than point nine nine
so it looks like it gets into the cycle
of bouncing between
three separate values even though in in
theory in both of those cases we were
doing something that was I to the ex
iterated on itself it has everything to
do with what actual function you think I
to the ex is referring to so in that
sense the power tower question is
ambiguous usually you just choose it to
be the pi-halves i variant but it's more
fun to see that it can be multiple
things all right we have addition
multiplication exponentiation tetration
can we think of something in between
halfway between multiplication and
exponentiation oh that's a I mean I love
the spirit of it because each one of
them it comes down to like a discrete
step of you're repeating the previous
operation but often times in math when
you have something initially defined in
terms of repetition like exponentiation
you can extend it beyond that I can't
think of anything off the top of my head
but that's an interesting question I
don't know if that's been that's an
extended notion I mean you have things
like fractional derivatives you have
things like fractional and the complex
exponents so it doesn't seem outlandish
but I'm not familiar with one myself and
then lastly do complex numbers for the
power of complex number values arise in
physics and if yes how does one decide
which values are valid so I can't think
of if they necessary necessary seen
switching I can't think of if they come
up in physics in like a direct sense and
this is probably just because I'm not a
physicist so I would say like ask ask
your neighborhood physicist and see what
they have to say
I mean clearly the point of teaching the
lesson here is that the thoughts that
you have to go through to make sense out
of it do build a stronger relationship
with Exponential's things like it's not
just more natural to represent them as e
to the RX once you get to complex
numbers you kind of have to represent
them that way
whereas previously in like physics or
other real-world contexts it's something
that's just nice